Lo que haremos en este video es pensar en una
forma de medir ángulos, y hay varias formas de
hacer esto. Es posible que hayan visto esto como
incrementos en grados en otros videos, pero ahora
vamos a presentar un nuevo concepto o verlo de
otra manera. Así que tenemos este ángulo ABC y
queremos pensar de qué manera podemos calcular
la medida del ángulo ABC. Una forma de pensarlo
es que este ángulo subtiende un arco, en este
caso subtiende el arco AC, y podemos ver que si
este ángulo fuera más pequeño, si su medida fuera
más pequeña, subtendería un arco más pequeño,
subtendería un arco más pequeño, la longitud de este arco sería menor; y si elángulo fuera más ancho o tuviera una medida mayor,
algo así, entonces la longitud del arco sería
mayor, de modo que ¿deberíamos definir la medida
de un ángulo, como este, como igual a la longitud
del arco que subtiende? ¿Esta es una buena
medición? Bueno, algunos de ustedes pueden ver
inmediatamente un problema, porque esta longitud,
la longitud del arco que subtiende, no sólo
depende de la medida del ángulo, también depende
de qué tan grande sea el círculo con el que estás
trabajando, si el radio es mayor entonces tendrás
una mayor longitud de arco. Por ejemplo, permíteme
hacer otro círculo aquí. Tenemos la misma medida
del ángulo central justo aquí; se podría decir
que el ángulo ABC sigue siendo el mismo pero ahora
subtiende arcos diferentes en estos dos círculos.
Tienes este arco aquí, llamemos a este arco DE,
y la longitud del arco DE no es igual a la
longitud de AC, así que no podemos medir el ángulo
sólo por la longitud del arco que subtiende si
ese ángulo es un ángulo central en un círculo,
podemos deshacernos de este signo. ¿Pero qué
podríamos hacer? Bueno, te darás cuenta de que
estas rebanadas que acabo de crear, podríamos
decir: la rebanada ABC y la rebanada DBE,
son rebanadas semejantes. Ahora, no estamos
acostumbrados a hablar en términos de rebanadas
semejantes, pero ¿qué significa ser semejante?
Bueno, tenemos semejanzas y podemos mapear una
cosa en otra, una forma en otra, no sólo a través
de transformaciones rígidas sino también a través
de homotecias, y en esta situación, si tuviéramos
que tomar la rebanada ABC y hacer una homotecia
con un factor de escala mayor que 1, existiría
algún factor de escala con el que podamos hacer
la homotecia hasta DBE. Y, ahora, lo interesante
de esto es que si dos cosas son semejantes eso
significa que las razones entre las partes
correspondientes van a ser iguales, así que,
por ejemplo, la razón de la longitud del arco AC
a la longitud del segmento BC va a ser igual a
la razón de la longitud del arco DE a la longitud
del segmento BE, de modo que tal vez esta sea una
buena medida para un ángulo. Y de hecho es una
medida que usamos en geometría y trigonometría y
en matemáticas, y la llamamos medida de un ángulo
en radianes, y es igual a la razón de la longitud
del arco subtendido por ese ángulo al radio.
Acabamos de ver eso en ambas situaciones. Veamos
si podemos hacer esto un poco más claro. Digamos
que tenemos un círculo aquí y tiene un punto
central, llamemos ese punto F, y luego, déjenme
crear un ángulo, en realidad podríamos hacer un
ángulo recto, entonces llamemos a este punto F,
a este punto G y a este H, y digamos que este
radio es de 2 m. Ahora, ¿cuál será la longitud
del arco subtendido por el ángulo GFH? Bueno,
esto podría ser igual a 1/4 de la circunferencia
de todo este círculo que he dibujado, así que
toda la circunferencia podríamos escribirlo
aquí: la circunferencia va a ser igual a 2 πr,
que es igual a 2 π x 2 m que es igual a 4 πm. Así
que si esta longitud de arco es 1/4 de eso, esto
va a ser igual a πm. Con base en esta longitud de
arco, y este radio ¿cuál será la medida del ángulo
GFH en radianes? Bueno podríamos decir: la medida
del ángulo GFH en radianes es igual a la razón
entre la longitud del arco subtendido y el radio,
así que es igual a πm / 2 m. Cancelamos 2 m y es
igual a π / 2, ¿π / 2 qué? Bueno, esto es igual
a π / 2 radianes. Ahora, una cosa a considerar
es por qué los llamamos radianes, parece que se
relaciona con la palabra radio y una forma de
pensar en esto es que al dividir esta longitud
entre la longitud del radio estamos calculando
cuántos radios son equivalentes a la longitud del
arco en cuestión. De modo que en esta situación
un radio se vería algo así. Si tomamos la misma
longitud y la marcamos aquí, podemos ver que va
a ser igual a 1 punto y algo radios, y por eso
también podríamos decir 1 punto y algo radianes,
si tomamos π y lo dividimos entre 2 vamos a tener
un poco más de 1, vamos a tener 1 punto y algo.